The joe rogan experience.
So there's really like man eating crocodiles.
Oh yeah.
Well there's,
there's definitely Matt.
Any crocodiles?
Is this Jim Shockey?
Yeah,
this is my friend Jim.
And this guy is missing.
Yeah,
it's in Mozambique.
This guy's missing and hand.
This guy's missing his whole arm.
The fence will no wonder they Jim,
he's a lovely Canadian fellow who travels everywhere.
So they,
they've,
he's a hunter and they flew him in to kill these crocodiles for them.
Nice.
It's crazy.
I mean,
look at that fucking thing.
You imagine you're living right there and there's just God damn dinosaurs
everywhere.
No.
And furthermore,
if you can,
if you can get rid of the,
I don't know,
it must be a learned behavior because most crocodiles aren't doing that.
It's just that they're near people.
They'll,
they,
their brains are so small and there's so,
so reptilian.
Well,
they're just trying to do is eat.
And if it's a moving,
they're going to try to eat it.
And if it's a person solid,
they're targeting people,
but they found out that they can get peach crocodiles.
I don't think they're just going to eat any old thing.
I think they eat everything they can eat their giant.
Talking about 1800 pound lizard,
it's been the same.
It's exactly the same form for 60 plus million years.
You could say the same about sharks and they don't just go eat you.
They would if they could,
if they just decided to start in with the parks and the people they don't eat
get eaten by sharks.
No,
they don't.
They don't ever,
no one's ever been eating mushrooms like very occasionally,
no break.
They are not eaten by sharks generally.
Don't have a taste for our blood is what you're saying.
Yeah.
We're not on the menu.
We're not on the menu,
but they will eat us.
They will bite you to get you out of their zone or they might mistake you and
bite you.
They you,
cause they think there's something else,
but they don't,
you're saying eat,
which means like you sit down and you finish the meal.
Right.
I think that rarely happens.
Usually they just bite you in half and just,
you know,
follow this tastes like shit.
Fuck,
oh my zone.
You know,
and like that's the
animals that actively target people and it becomes a giant problem.
Like an India.
In India,
there's this river,
this place called the Sunderbans.
Oh,
the bull sharks.
No,
no.
These are tigers.
Tiger Shark.
He pulls bull sharks are very aggressive and they do kill people.
But these aren't tiger sharks.
Are Tigers.
Just the cat.
They kill a lot of people.
Kelly.
Yeah.
The the shit out of you.
Now sit down and like put the Napkin in their color and get like,
they're like,
yeah.
Yeah.
Well,
the actively hunt people in this one place and they've been doing it for
hundreds of years.
If they said over the last 200 years,
300,000 people have been killed by tigers in the Sunderbans.
Alright.
Yup.
Over the last 200 years,
300,000 people have been killed by tigers.
I don't know what to do with that number.
It seems implausible is insane.
Well,
it's just so common.
First of all,
India has a billion people,
right?
And a lot of them are really poor and they live in by these rivers and these
cats are everywhere and it's tall grass.
You've ever seen that video of the cat,
that giant tiger leaping up and attacking the guy when he's on an elephant?
No.
This is ash shows.
Yeah.
Well shows you pull it up.
Me,
it shows you how crazy India is.
This guy's on top of an elephant and he's walking this elephant through this
grass and this tiger runs through the grass and leaps up into the air and fucks
him up always on this elephant.
Okay.
I shouldn't laugh,
but it's kind of funny.
It's like,
it's kind of funny.
What a hell of a tiger.
They're,
they're insane.
I mean,
if a tiger was in a movie as a monster,
it'd be what we want to scare us.
Monsters.
Everybody that's on Youtube by the,
Oh yeah,
we can't play it on youtube,
but just everyone knows what it is.
Yeah.
Everyone can easily it on.
You don't pull it down because somebody owns this.
They have a copyright.
So here's the guy,
so he's on top of this elephant.
Now look at the grass and they spot it and then the thing,
yeah,
Whoa,
Yep.
Is on.
Oh my God.
Jumps jump
and it's going after him.
It knows that he's up there.
Look at it.
It's like bitch.
Well if I were the elephant and I just messed that tiger up,
tore the guy's arm apart.
The elephant didn't give a fuck.
It's just hanging out.
I looked the elephants like whatever bitch tigers can't kill me.
No,
I'm fine.
Even outside,
just stomp on it.
Pretty sure tigers
don't kill elephants,
but lions do.
And when lions do,
they're really hungry and they get a bunch of them and they gang up on an
elephant.
Okay.
Don't talk about it cause you're going to talk about the baby elephants that get
ganged up on first.
Oh this is not even necessarily babies.
They'll take out a real elephant.
Well not if it's with the herd.
What is this?
Trying to save a goat woman fights off tiger with a stick.
Let to go Chrysler Lee.
I like the kangaroo punching ones.
Those,
that's my name.
That dude,
I want to marry.
That dude
squaring off.
He's like trying to figure it out.
People were mad at that guy who's so cute.
But if you're an animal lover is going to the Kangaroos followup,
his dog Kangaroos,
those male kangaroos fight all the time.
They're always like punching.
That was just like a really fun.
Yeah,
and he's to get his dog.
So I would do this thing run right out there.
It's cause it's got the dog because this guy is so awesome.
Those are so weird.
They don't even seem real.
They seem to human.
Yeah,
look at that.
Look,
here we go.
Turn off thinking about it.
Bam.
I was like,
yeah bitch.
I just love the kangaroo does not know what to do.
He's like,
am I supposed to fight you?
He's so cute.
It's like fuck this.
What a weird animal.
But it bounces off like that on two legs guy though,
right?
Oh yeah,
for sure.
And also that he didn't follow up.
What do you think they were?
What was it doing like just fighting it or play it on a dog was barking.
The kangaroo decided to grab a of dog and get him in a headlock and that's what
they do.
That's right.
Like that's like generally giving you time to react a different way.
That's giving you a moment to not escalate.
Yes,
sure.
Because the dogs,
let me,
if you see the beginning of the video,
he's running around this kangaroo,
he thinks he's hunting.
He thinks he's like alerting his company in the car to the target.
Right.
If you don't even seem like a real animal,
they seem like something from an avatar movie.
Right.
I want to cuddle with them all when I see like,
wow,
I was like,
all I want is to take them all home and just cuddle with them.
The guy punched him right in the face and look at the fur on its belly.
You know that for on their bellies.
Really like soft.
Do you think that's a mamma?
Do you think that was?
I think that's a dude.
That's a dude.
I don't see.
I don't see,
well,
he's not as big as he's,
I think that's a woman.
It might be because she's not very big.
Well.
That also makes sense to that.
That's what that pouches were.
The Tummy.
What's happening?
I think there's a little thing right there.
It says something.
Oh,
what's that?
What?
That little thing hanging down there.
You see now the tails back here?
No,
that can't be the penis tales.
Huge.
Right?
Oh wait,
move it.
Move in a second.
No,
that is a penis.
Yeah.
Come on.
Where's the ball bouncing around?
There it is.
Maybe that's just like the curtain for the vast,
they are very developed kangaroo.
He's not going to win many fights.
He's sort of a Beta there,
right?
There's some giant Kangaroos,
those big scary world.
So cause this one knocking on the door.
Hey Man.
Oh,
let me look at the clause.
And it was fun.
Yeah,
that's scary.
That's what I'm saying.
When he put the dog in the headlock,
he could easily have taken care of that dog.
But he didn't.
He like,
yeah,
he kept the head.
He was like,
I'm shutting this down.
I really think we're mis-gendering.
Yes.
I think we're mis-gendering that kangaroo like it's a girl.
Oh,
that one looks like a dude.
See you look the difference.
You see his car?
No,
I think they're the same.
That's the same.
That one's super jazzed to do it.
Why?
Maybe kangaroo chases people.
Cause that's muscles as it really chasing people.
Yeah.
Cause it has muscles.
Maybe it's a female that Gus does a lot of crossfit for the secret life of
golfers.
Like there's,
there's crocodiles on the golf courses,
there's Kangaroos.
What else is going on for those lightning?
Okay.